[Music]
somehow though it would seem that the
daily cancellation was made for her lena
dunham has i don't think ever been
canceled on this show sadly she dropped
off the face of the earth right around
the time when i began this segment some
might even speculate that the timing was
not a coincidence perhaps she fled from
public view in order to avoid the wrath
of the daily cancellation she was
briefly back on the radar early in 2021
when she released a plus-sized fashion
line that was immediately slammed by
critics for not catering to fat people
enough
um the world crowd claimed that dunham's
new brand failed the inclusivity test
because though it had clothing for large
people it did not have any for very
large and very very large people
so dunham's attempt to relaunch her
career crashed and burned
as the woke zombies swarmed the rocket
before takeoff and devoured everybody
inside which is probably why they need
bigger clothing but now dunham is making
her real comeback and last week a
lengthy puff piece in the hollywood
reporter
featuring glamour shots like this one
which you can see here
there you go
uh feast your eyes on that for a moment
announced that dunham was back on the
scene and she's not going anywhere and
her new film
sharp stick has debuted the website
moviemaker.com quotes her q a after the
premiere at sundance where she explains
what the film is about and what she
hopes to achieve with it the article
says quote lena dunham's sharpstick
shows the porn industry in a rare
positive light she says that was 100
intentional
now
side note you're of course filled with a
deep sense of foreboding at the thought
that lena dunham directed and starred in
a film about porn
but just put your mind at ease
we're not playing any clips
we will stick instead with what she has
said about the movie and continuing she
says i think many of us were especially
people who started maybe like reading
second wave feminist literature early we
were shaped by a kind of feminism that
maybe didn't give porn it's due as
something that can be really healing for
people
dunham who directed wrote and acted in
sharp sticks said saturday in a q a
after the film's world premiere at
sundance quote i think we have found
we have enough messaging in society and
probably in my 20s i contributed to it
that said like porn is ruining sex and
it's making it so hard for people but i
really wanted this to show the way that
porn can liberate people and that it's
an industry that's just as complicated
as hollywood and as vast and probably
more prolific and i think that's really
important for us to recognize the very
healthy role that porn can play and the
important role that porn actors play in
shaping people's identities
now we should mention here that dunham's
new film has been described even by
mainstream critics who are predisposed
to appreciate dunham's work as quote
heinous hollow amateurish cringe
uncomfortable and problematic
those are also all the adjectives that i
would use to describe a lena dunham
starring film about the wonders of porn
even though i haven't seen it i never
will because i'd sooner scoop my own
eyes out with a rusty spoon than
watch something like that but even if
the film fails to impress the critics
the basic message is one that would
generally enjoy wide agreement among
many people in our culture especially on
the left
porn
is liberating and empowering
we're told healing even has dunham
claims
is that true
in a word no
pornography is about as liberating
empowering and healing as heroin
when dunham calls it all of those things
what she really means is that it's
pleasurable
and she draws no distinction between
pleasure and liberation
or pleasure and joy or pleasure and love
because for her as for so many others in
our culture momentary pleasure is the
highest good that we can hope to achieve
a life packed full of moments of surface
level pleasure
is mistaken then for a fulfilled and
joyful life
that is these two things are mistaken
until you look around and see the
results
because if porn is so wonderful and
healing then you'd expect for one thing
that the people in the porn industry
would be the most joyful and healed of
all
and yet we find among people in that
line of work
sky-high rates of suicide and drug abuse
just as we find among prostitutes
and the people who appear in porn videos
are just prostitutes after all
as for the viewer when you look at porn
you become a faceless onlooker peering
like a stalker through the window of a
motel while someone else has sex with a
hooker they hired on the street corner
but it's worse than that really because
it's less honest
at least the peeping tom is forced to
reckon with his behavior he's out in the
cold ducking behind bushes watching
these two go at it
and from there he sees the whole act the
whole dismal exchange he doesn't get to
dip in and out of a dozen scenes
consuming portions and glances before
breezing along to the next
he doesn't get to close the tab when
it's all over and act like nothing
happened
he's there as a stranger in the dark and
he has to go home and deal with the
reality of what he's become
the porn viewer on the other hand feels
insulated
what he's doing really is identical in a
lot of ways but it doesn't seem that way
because it's safer it's a screen not a
window
she's an amateur porn star not a
prostitute
his actions are legal
even normal by today's standards
well he's different he tells himself
he's better
that's a lie because everything about
porn is a lie
porn makes human beings into objects
it turns a sexual act into something
transactional and mercenary
you know sex between a married couple in
the privacy of their bedroom is an
expression of love and devotion so then
what does sex on camera for the viewing
public express
and what does the viewer ex what does
the viewer express by viewing it
i mean the supporters of porn they're
the first ones to claim
that this is an act of expression
okay
i'll take you at your word what is it
expressing exactly
certainly not empowerment
a woman who feels like she has power
over her life does not [ __ ] herself out
to the porn industry and a man or woman
for that matter who feels like he has
power over his own life does not make a
[ __ ] of himself by watching it
the porn industry along with sites like
pornhub and so on they profit off of the
willful self-degradation of both the
viewer and the view to the tune of many
billions of dollars
you know it's hard to argue that
consumers are ever really empowered in
their role as consumer
even when they're consuming something
innocuous or morally neutral
i've never felt empowered while waiting
in line at target
which isn't to say that there's anything
morally wrong with shopping at a real
retail outlet it's just to say that i
would never try to find anything poetic
or beautiful about the experience
so then what about consumers of the porn
industries product
if you're not empowered while pushing a
cart around the aisles of a big box
retailer
how in the hell could you be empowered
in your role as a faceless third party
participant in virtual prostitution
and how could the prostitutes themselves
be empowered
no everyone involved is being used
dehumanized and objectified
far from being healed they're being
damaged
though they may find some pleasure in
the harm being done to them
just as you may find pleasure in the
brain damage you suffer from drinking
too much whiskey
that can't be confused with joy
or least of all empowerment
this is all why today finally we have
the honor to say to lena dunham you are
cancelled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends